valérie bénaïm il ya un mois drake était
à paris pour une série de concerts on a
fait croire à valérie que pour tpm paix
à la les interviewer la star américaine
autant vous dire j'ai cru grec pour
valérie bénaïm c'est marc lévy pour qui
c'est pas trop qui sait y est rihanna
piège valérie bénaïm vous allez voir
parce que la ressemblance c'est vraiment
le sosie ans rihanna est amusé à les
voir c'est maintenant sur ces 8 c'est
ton direct c'est la grande race rats et
valérie c'est la première fois que je la
vois ce faire galocher non oui dans une
dans une main tenant à sa demande
et oui regardez elle est coquine la bnl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci ou avec jane chrono
qu'il a un petit peu de retard du coup
en bas juste attendre et s'il vous plaît
voilà après vous pouvez commenter à pois
il ya quelqu'un qui arrive est un combat
ça doit pas être autant ok c'était
forcément les baisers oui de se passer
après excusez moi mais son prix mais
valérie benaïm ou est ce qu'on peut
faire une petite photo mais je vous en
parle avec amour avec plaisir ça va plus
on paie cash et moi je vous en prie avec
la aucun souci avec moi si tu aimes va
très bien merci
[Musique]
c'est dommage on aurait dit bonjour
f s
ensuite cette fouille est désormais
d'accord ensuite moi
les gens avaient essayé d'éviter de le
fixer dans les yeux merci allez-y vous
pouvez venir s'il vous plaît oui vous
pouvez écarter les jambes s'il vous
plaît donnez vous vous en prie vous
aviez quand même ce serait mieux invité
d'un travesti d'accord merci beaucoup
[Musique]
doucement
merci infiniment de nous avoir accordé
cette interview
évidemment la toute première question de
les opposer c'est ce que c'est votre
première fois en france est ce que vous
aimez la france reçoit sur comment
trouvez-vous le public français qu'est
ce que vous ne trouvez particulier
celles ci que votre secret pour
enchaîner comme ça tube sur tube il sur
8 millions contre ma personne qui lui
avait fait redescendre à laval pleine
discussion ou là
[Musique]
la vidéo est très sérieuse et comment
actuellement l'année
[Musique]
chez sony
tabesh
[Musique]
john mayer feig donc enfin ya mario
global tech i can't ok ok c'est ok a war
is back
[Applaudissements]
interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien
mais qui ressemblaient à ceux des
ricochets s'agit en fait
[Applaudissements]